[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs tout de suite le
sommaire annulée pour cause d'épidémie
la foire de chatou revient à partir de
ce vendredi
nous sommes allés en avant-première voir
des stands les exposants les escales
game jeu de rôle grandeur nature font le
plein de visiteurs dans les yvelines les
salles souvent les unes après les autres
nous verrons pourquoi ce loisir à la
cote et puis enfin l'agenda complet de
vos sorties du week end
au programme un atelier des chansons et
du cinéma
si vous aimez chiner ou vous trouvez des
bibelots insolite
la foire de château ouvre ses portes ce
vendredi 25 septembre jusqu'au 4 octobre
elle réédite sa 100e édition du à sa
fermeture précipitée en mars à cause de
la qu'ovide astrid bergère est allé
faire un tour en avant première la foire
de chatou est la plus grande foire de
france elle est réunie pendant dix jours
plus de 400 antiquaires et brocanteurs
toujours ravi d'être là il ya toujours
une bonne ambiance c'est une bonne foire
avec plein de stands et de marchandises
différentes voilà il y en a un peu pour
pour tous les goûts
cette année la foire sera un peu
particulière en raison de la situation
sanitaire à plus de mille personnes en
même temps sur le site gel
hydroalcoolique sur tous les stands et
surtout masque obligatoire ceva hyper
pratique de travailler en termes de
relations commerciales avec un masque
effectivement c'est le plus compliqué
pour créer le contact le dialogue etc
mais bon on n'a pas le choix donc on le
fait malgré ces mesures les
organisateurs espèrent attirer 30 mille
personnes la foire de chatou se
distingue par la variété d'objets
proposés à la vente
antiquaires et brocanteurs se côtoient
c'est vraiment une fois de passionnés
nous sommes antiquaires en passionné qui
transmettront à d'autres passionnés qui
vont venir voilà pendant ces dix jours
d'ouverture qui vont se faire un plaisir
de
de venir chiner dernier dans les allées
et pour les prix il y à du tout au
niveau budget au niveau budget ce qui
est fantastique h à tous ces cons on
peut acheter un arrosoir à 5 euros en
zinc et acheter des pièces à des
milliers d'euros cette année le prix
saint roch le patron des antiquaires
sera remis à yves lecoq cette semaine
dans les yvelines la danse est à
l'honneur avec votre enfant
venez danser autour de l'univers du
conte de la princesse au petit pois
samedi 26 septembre de 15h à 16h
l'espace philippe noiret ouais à
l'espace pardon philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois une séance ludique pour
partager un moment de détente avec toute
la famille
dans un autre registre le nautic parc
sur l'île de la chaussée à bougival
propose un après-midi guinguette gratuit
ce dimanche
ambiance festive garantie et une session
concert aura lieu à la médiathèque du
canal à montigny le bretonneux de 17h à
18h30
elle donne carte blanche à des musiciens
locaux qui souhaitent se faire connaître
[Musique]
plutôt blonde blanche ambrée ou brunes
pas besoin de choisir vous l'aurez
compris toutes les sortes de bières
seront présentes à l'abir fest la
première fête de la bière de
noisy-le-roi organisée par l'association
des commerçants du village
l'événement aura lieu ce samedi de 10h à
22h et pour en parler sur ce plateau
avec nous estime brasier bonsoir soir
alors à quoi d'autre s'attendre pour
cette première édition alors c'est un
projet de développement local
en fait ils veulent favoriser la
consommation de produits en circuit
court
alors on le rappelle bien évidemment la
consommation d'alcool et l'alcool est à
consommer avec modération
l'objectif c'est que ça devienne un
événement annuel est donc cette année
ils ont invité cinq brasseur lieu
yvelinois participé à l'édition il y
aura la brasserie de la reine thé rbl de
bill gates district et puis la brasserie
toussaint ils seront tous là pour faire
déguster leurs produits
elle met aussi partagez on a fait le
choix de travailler avec 100 grasser on
a fait le choix de ne pas multiplier les
brasseurs
pour la simple raison qu'on voulait que
les gens les connaissent le tout c'est
pas lui c'est pas le pas tous les deux
les goûters ce pacte ou de boire c'est
il faut il faut connaître les gens
voulaient rencontrer ces gracieux en
même temps d'aller les voir notre temps
discuter avec eux c'est une suite
meilleure expérience humaine et puis
pour nos brasseurs à leur tour également
alors est ce qu'il ya une raison
particulière pour faire une fête sur la
bière oui tout à fait donc comme vous
l'avez dit célia le festival est
organisé par l'association des
commerçants de noisy-le-roi forcément ce
ne sont pas tous des brasseurs et donc
ils ont choisi la bière tout simplement
pour donner une visibilité plus
importante selon l'activité brassicole
dans les yvelines se développe mais
manque de promotion est donc cet
événement c'est quelque chose qui leur
semblait important pour les mettre en
avant
on a choisi l'activité brassicole parce
qu'elle nous a semblé être dynamique et
en manque dans une vitrine d'un lieu où
elles pouvaient s'exprimer plus
simplement voilà on a c'est une première
on fait on fait un essai grandeur nature
et on va on va tout faire pour que ça se
passe bien elle la journée se veut
festive le stand des brasseurs
restauration ou encore cochon grillé sur
les trottoirs mais aussi des animations
il y aura notamment un groupe de musique
qui va jouer pendant trois heures et qui
vont même peut-être déambuler dans la
rue c'est un c'est un cadeau surprise
nous ce qu'on sait c'est qu'on aura
trois heures d'une vingtaine de
musiciens qui vont jouer toute la
période du déjeuner qui vont se déplacer
dans toute la rue voilà on se réjouit de
les accueillir mais je pense qu'on va
tous avoir une très bonne surprise
et puis le soir ce sera plus festif et
une ambiance plus feutrée et plus mais
on a on a une grosse journée tous
ensemble donc cette première d'hier fait
ce sera un événement convivial si je
comprends bien oui bien sûr bien sûr
mais attention les organisateurs restent
très vigilants aux règles sanitaires en
vigueur bien sûr comme un peu partout
maintenant il y aura du gel
hydroalcoolique à disposition le masque
est obligatoire et puis le parcours sera
fléché
mais en plus de ça il y aura une prise
de température à l'entrée du festival
alors est-ce que vous pouvez peut-être
nous rappeler les informations pratiques
pour cette journée bien sûr alors la
première fête de la bière à noisy le roi
va se dérouler le samedi 26 septembre
ça sera rue andré le pour bhl entre 10h
et 22h
il y aura trois parkings prévus pour
l'occasion un à la gare à la mairie et
puis un en haut de la rue et puis
attention parce que la rue sera
interdite au stationnement dès le
vendredi soir
bien merci justin pour toutes ces
informations et puis on se retrouve
comme d'habitude la semaine prochaine
pour aller aux nouvelles reliques dans
les yvelines les escape game ne
désemplissent pas
de plus en plus ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux ils doivent donc sans cesse
renouvelé leur thème pour attirer
toujours plus les clients
exemple à saint germain en laye où une
nouvelle salle vient d'être ouverte
un montage de l'ucap houdart vont-ils
trouver les trésors des rois de france
passé par saint germain en laye telle
est l'énigme de la toute nouvelle salle
la mine
ouverte il ya moins d'un mois et la
quatrième de l'entreprise en deux ans un
succès qui s'explique par la singularité
des énigmes selon nous c'est de faire
des sales original concret nous mêmes de
a à z des scénarios on les choisit nous
mêmes aussi nous qui créons les énigmes
les décors c'est nous qui les concevons
et c'est aussi de ba de faire de la
qualité donc on essaie de faire des
salles bien réfléchi avec des mécanismes
innovants par mois ce sont mille
visiteurs qui viennent essayer les
différentes salles proposé ce jour là
ils étaient trois amis à vouloir se
mettre dans la peau de chercheurs d'or
pendant une heure c'est l'idée de
un scénario pendant une heure c'est un
peu comme je le jeu vidéo mais dans la
vraie vie autrement
kerra on est à sa 5ème énigme elle a
commencé à comprendre les rouages des
escales de game sans pour autant gagner
à tous les coups
peut-être qu'on est plus concentré sur
les petits détails etc on sait par qui
est un peu moins mais après ça dépend
aussi de la difficulté et puis des gens
avec qui on le fait si la communication
est bonne et puis le mode aussi dans
lequel on est le jour même un son envie
de réussir ou pas du tout et aujourd'hui
les trois amis avaient l'envi de trouver
le trésor
le fait de coopérer entre les joueurs
pour résoudre un mystère est aussi un
avantage d escape game n'y a pas
vraiment de notion de concurrence entre
les joueurs qui viennent ensemble et
c'est en fait les gens viennent
rechercher l'immersion ensemble quoi
c'est comme si vous étiez avec vos amis
ou votre famille dans des décors de
disneyland ou de cinéma
rien qu'à vous rendre pour vous pour
résoudre des énigmes et où est ben c'est
ça qui plaît beaucoup dans quelques mois
de nouvelles salles vont être ouvertes à
saint-germain-en-laye dont shoop shoop
est un scénario décalé et humoristique
les joueurs devront retrouver choupette
un yorkshire d'une riche saint
germanoise sachant que les ravisseurs
sont peut-être des chats vaudou qui
serait à l'origine de plusieurs
disparitions de chiens et si vous
n'aimez pas les esters game d'autres
activités sont prévues ce week end comme
apprendre à réduire ses déchets et à
consommer moins de plastique un atelier
zéro déchet sera proposée samedi à 10h30
à la médiathèque jean rosselot à
guyancourt
dans le cadre de la semaine du
développement durable l'échappée belle
chanson pour un embouteillage c'est le
titre complet de ce spectacle pour les
enfants de 3 à 7 ans qui se déroulera ce
dimanche au quai 3 opecst
à 17h le thème deux amis sont coincés
dans un embouteillage pour passer le
temps elle rêve rond imagineront
chanteront et enfin un dernier week end
pour profiter du labyrinthe deux
hectares de champs de maïs à la ferme de
romainville située à magny les hameaux
et ouvert de 14h à 18h30 une activité à
faire en famille sur un parcours de 3 km
environ mille visiteurs sont venus cet
été un bon billet un bon bilan pour
mélanie de la lande l'agricultrice qui
s'occupe du labyrinthe
il est vraiment de
voilà de nos portes de l'ancienne
activité sympa de faire venir les
familles et les enfants aussi de
proposer une activité qui changent
puisque un peu d'agriculteurs son
secteur et voilà beaucoup labyrinthe de
maïs dans la région et aussi forcément
de parler du magasin est de montrer aux
gens on est on est accessible on n'est
pas loin on est une ferme a vraiment eu
du modèle portes de la ville nouvelle
que faut-il aller voir au cinéma cette
semaine
la parole est donnée aux programmateurs
des halles saint-quentinoise
et aujourd'hui c'est bertrand pigné de
l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois qui nous parle de deux
films les choses qu'on dit les choses
qu'on fait est énorme au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude dans les
salles de l'espace philippe noiret cette
semaine
tnet évidemment mais deux films français
surtout puisqu'il faut aussi parler de
la production hexagonale qui irait
arrive dans les salles et qui prend le
risque de revenir dans les salles alors
que le public a encore du mal à y
revenir
je vous parlais de deux films un film
qui s'appelle les choses qu'on dit les
choses qu'on fait un film d'amour une
grande fresque de deux heures d'amour
d'histoire d'amour de gens qui se
raconte des histoires d'amour quelque
chose de très léger de très beaux avec
camélia jordana et vincent macaigne et
niels schneider
un film de emmanuel mouret une comédie
romantique qui je pense pourra plaire à
beaucoup de monde
garçons comme filles puisque voilà c'est
c'est des choses très touchante
un deuxième film aussi qui est un peu un
coup de coeur qui s'appelle énorme
l'histoire d'un homme qui
devient enceintes en même temps que sa
femme qu'il a mis enceinte par
forfanterie un film de sophie letourneur
qui est une réalisatrice trop peu
présente sur nos écrans et avec jonathan
cohen et marina foïs de comédie donc une
romantique une plus délirantes deux
choses à aller voir à l'espace philippe
noiret de cette semaine et c'est la fin
de ses études choisir merci de nous
avoir suivis rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour de nouvelles idées
sorties même endroit même heure
bonne soirée à jeudi prochain
[Musique]